i have i still have the audition and i
i'm proud of it i had a wig and i was
like you know you killed it i
had 14 over six months fourteen dude
when i heard about this i called my all
my manager molly and i said i'm the
biggest stooge fan there is i gotta go
in and i gotta go do this and she said
you're not a celebrity and you're not a
comedian i don't think i can get you an
appointment and it was a friend of mine
that called me that was like hey are you
going to the stooges thing and i was
he's like you're a student fan right i
was like yeah
he's like are you going i was like yeah
yeah when are you going he's like i'm
going on friday i was like yeah where is
that he's like well i was like where is
it again did you just show up yep
you hold on a second you had no audition
no agent representation going into that
i mean you had an agent i had an agent
but you just you just signed in i went
to a hasidic
wig shop and bought a wig i cut a wig i
went to a foam latex foam store and i
padded my neighbor's suit my neighbor's
much bigger than me so that i could lose
my neck and fill out some girth
and i got to the audition
and at the audition there was a big sign
that said do not come in character
and i walked in there and i saw these
guys and jeans and a t-shirt and i was
like
what the how the are they gonna
find mo larry and curly
like looking like this is ridiculous and
so when the casting director came out i
remember it was rick montgomery he
opened the door and he went hey
he looked at me and cautioned it was a
ridiculous costume but he was
just like oh god
all right come on in and i and i went in
and it was one there was one page of
sides it was just one page of sides i
didn't you had that little bowl cut i
had the bowl cut and i didn't do the
sides i did i did a uh i did a bunch of
little things from from the shorts you
you know you see that store over there
each one of us grab a broom we go out
and we sweep in front of the place the
boss comes out sees three conscientious
guys and offers us a job it's simple
come on get going i did i did all this
and they were like huh and then and
then they were like okay come back
um and and i got a note and they were
like your costume's terrible
so you if you're gonna come in costume
you've got to do something better so i
hired christian tinsley who did the
makeup for the passion of the christ
and i got him to do under eye bags on me
and a full face cast and i
my wife was doing a show warner brothers
went
above and beyond what anybody else would
do and you didn't even have an audition
i had to get i didn't have i had to get
it i was the guy i had to i had to i had
to get it and i i i broke into the
warner brothers costume
warehouse and i borrowed a fat suit and
period clothes and i
went back over and over and over again
they kept bringing me back kept bringing
me back kept bringing me back and then
i wouldn't hear anything in costume in
like you i never went out not only in
costume in character i would sign in and
hi hi boss how you doing i never ever
ever people looking at you like holy yes
they thought i was a lunatic and
and who cares and pete was pete would go
well it's mo it's mo and and and bob and
bobby was like yeah you do you you got
the mo thing i was like oh thank you
very much and they were like
all right all right and i would any time
i'd go in i'd try and find a moment to
do something slap sticky like in one of
my auditions i pretended i didn't see
the chair i fell right over it and uh
and they all got up from their chairs
like they thought it really happened and
and it it every moment was a chance to
show them a little bit more that i
understood the stooges but dude i got my
heart broken so many times because i
remember reading variety right after an
audition
right after one of the auditions that
johnny knoxville got the part
and i was like oh my god
and then and it turns out pete told me
that he did have the part they offered
it to him he accepted and then
pete and johnny had a talk and johnny
was like well i'm not gonna do an
impression because i don't that's not
what i do it's gonna be like the modern
moe and pete was like no no this is the
stooges
and and johnny was like i'm not sure
this is gonna work and so then they went
back to the drawing board and they more
auditions and then i i
read sorry then my manager called and
said
i'm sorry it's the end of the line they
have offered it to hank's area
and they had and uh and he would have
been one they just kept going they saw
moe right in front of them and they kept
going around but he wanted too much
money
you